so we want to take the indefinite
integral of 4x to the 3rd over X to the
4th plus 7 DX so how can we tackle this
this seems like a hairy integral now the
key inside here is to realize that you
have this expression X to the 4th plus 7
and you also have its derivative up here
the derivative of X to the 4th plus 7 is
equal to 4x so third derivative of X to
the fourth is 4x to the third derivative
of 7 is just 0 so that's a big clue that
u substitution might be the tool of
choice here u sub I'll just write u well
write don't they use substitution could
be the tool of choice so given that what
would you want to set your u equal to
and I'll let you think about that
because if you can figure out this part
then the rest will just boil down to a
fairly straightforward integral well you
want to set u be equal to the expression
that you have its derivative laying
around so we could set u equal to X to
the fourth X to the fourth plus seven
now what is d u going to be equal to D u
I will do it in magenta D u well is just
going to just be the derivative of x to
the fourth plus seven with respect to X
so 4x to the 3rd plus 0 times DX times
DX I wrote it in differential form right
over here but it's a completely
equivalent statement to saying that D U
the derivative of u with respect to X is
equal to 4x third for X to the third
power when someone writes D u over DX
like this this is really a notation to
say the derivative of U with respect to
X it really isn't a fraction in in a
very formal way but oftentimes you can
you can kind of pseudo manipulate them
like fractions so if you wanted to go
from here to there you could you could
kind of pretend that you're multiplying
both sides by DX but these are
equivalent statements and we want to get
it in a differential form in order to do
proper u substitution and the reason why
this is useful and I'll just rewrite it
up here so that it becomes pretty
obvious our original integral we can
rewrite as 4x to the third
DX over X to the fourth plus seven and
then it's pretty clear what's D you and
what's you you which we set to be equal
to X to the fourth plus seven and then D
U is equal to this it's equal to four X
to the third DX we saw it right over
here so we could rewrite this integral
and I'll try to stay consistent with the
colors as the indefinite integral what
we have in magenta right over here
that's D u D u over try to stay true to
the colors over X to the fourth plus
seven which is just u or we could
rewrite this entire thing as the
integral of 1 over u 1 over u D u 1 over
u D u well what is the indefinite
integral of 1 over u D u well that's
just going to be equal to the natural
log of the absolute value and we use the
absolute value so it'll be defined even
for negative use and it actually does
work out and another video where I show
you that definitely does the natural log
of the absolute value of U and then we
might have had a constant there that law
was lost when we took the derivative so
that's what we that's essentially our
answer in terms of U but now we need to
unsubstituted when we unsubstituted this
is going to be equal to the natural log
of the absolute value of well U is X to
the 4th plus 7 X to the 4th plus 7 not C
plus 7 and then we can't forget our plus
C out here and we are done